καμείς για κιον το συνέσθυμα πουνιώθεις της συγκεκριμένι στιγμήις να περιμένει λες να περιμένεις τίπο
νκαμάο προάποτ να εβουλευτείς ποιος οποιο δήποτε κόμ επο κανένας αι ότε με διαφεραγίνο βουλευτή
τον άκ ντξει να μηκινις βουλευτείς αλλά υπάρχει έντον η συζήτηση ότι κάτι ετοιμάζει ο
χρησιστφορος το ναήτης είδαμε κάποιες αναρτίσεις ε μιλήσαμε και μαζί για ναα δούμε αν υπάρχει
τελικάνα κάνεις κόμα επροσέγκισε κάποια τομα νααμισκόμα γκίνηση πως να το ποί να τούτι συζήτησε
ξεκίνησε ναιβασουμε εξεκίνησαμε ται με τοφιδία λέγαμε ότε ένα κάμουμε τών το πράμα να μετά
νήτά ταυκάμλλαρα υκμε το όνομα πο ένα υκάλουμε μιλούσαμε για τα λέμε φός μετά πτον
έπερσαρέντεμετάαπο κί μετά ποτά μετ πμου γά στα καλύτραέτσει ίδα μια κατάσταση πυ την εξεκινήσα
που καιρώ εγώ να σου πω την αλήθεια α τοπω σκέφτουμε αυτή τη στεμή λέω
ότι τόσα χρόνια έχωβοήθεισα τόσο πολύ κόσμο να πια η θέσεις και ότμε πληγόσαν όλοη
δηλαδή τούτα τα πράγματα ς που εμε που βλέπω ι ραματίζουμε την κύπρο τα βλέπε
άει τώρα αγοέρα αυτόδα μέας πυμνε στελασουμια φωτοραφία ντα που γίνετ μ στο δρό καλά
να μποροσε τα χεο μια γέυτα δηλαδή που τα κρεμαστάα μετά διαυτείς ταν που στοιχιζο
το πράα ας πούμε διαδήθεασου π ότι έχει πολλά πράγματα τα οποία της τιώς εν
κάμι καρέα τίποτε να κάμισοκαι υπαρές σκέφτουμε καιότι είπα ότι θα προσπαθείσωτούν την πελάρα που
έχω θέλει να τηλαδή διατέρας και έρ ττα ό πελάρα την ιδιοφία μου τού τη
φήμη που έχωή τούτα που κάο ο τέλος πά πουμε ξέρουν ος ο κόσμο να
διοχιετεύσω του τι δύναμη σε κάποια η κανάτομα ο που προσπαθώ να ύρω ντάξει από
όλους τους τομίς και να τους αν α θα μια ομάδα να κατευούμε στα σε
πόμενες βουλευτικές εκλογές θαράντα τομα πεντα ότοαόστους εύρω να κάτουσομαζήτους να τους έκπαιδεύσω και να
εκπαιδευτούμε σε όλα τα θέματα να φέω το φιδί νανέχει την κανωσ εναι να αρτ
μας μυρίζει για τα τούς να μύτια ή